la récolte 2010 8 s'annonce généreuse et
hâtive et pour répondre à la demande
il vend quirion vient d'investir 5
millions de dollars dans son vignoble
demain saint jacques doubler sa
production donc il ya peut-être 60 % qui
est investi dans les vignes et l'autre
40% bâtiment qu ligne d'embouteillage
boutique donc et s'investit partout au
québec il ya des semaines aux 20,4 5000
bouteilles par semaine c'est incroyable
donc on vend aujourd'hui dans un monde
qu'on vendait dans un agneau dix ans de
2013 à 2017 la production de vins
québécois est passé de 1,4 million à 2 7
millions de bouteilles
l'accès à la saq et aux épiceries y est
pour quelque chose mais aussi la qualité
du produit les meilleurs producteurs
sont vite en rupture de stock
un ingénieur qui a des vins du québec
certifié ne fournit jamais à l'année de
tous ses 20 ans jamais on sent vraiment
une amie arrivée la consommation qui est
assez intimidant pour maintenir la
production et vignerons québécois
peuvent maintenant acheter du raisin
québécois de notre producteur sans
perdre leur certification de l'estrie à
l'île d'orléans plusieurs vignerons des
soucis en partie les vignes hybride pour
des cépages connu comme le chardonnay du
riesling ou le pinot noir
il faut toutefois mettre des protections
hivernales expertise d une langue entre
en jeu giovanni pcci raynaud biais d'une
famille de vignerons italien est passé
par l'université de bordeaux avant de
venir travailler au domaine saint
jacques
j'ai remarqué qu'ici les sons sont très
hétérogènes en fait donc on a un bon
potentiel pour les vins blancs et un bon
potentiel pour les oies rouge aussi moi
ce qui me semble inquiéter vraiment
c'était l'hiver avec marchés en
croissance
il ya de la place pour d'autres joueurs
dans l'industrie pour l'instant il ya
750 hectares de vignes en friture on
pourrait atteindre 4000 hectares dessine
douzaine d'années et on vise moi je les
minorités pendant des années les
vignerons du québec ont lutté pour se
trouver un marché maintenant leur
conseille plutôt qu'ils ne pourront
jamais répondre à la demande
ici michel marsolais radio-canada saint
jacques le mineur